Happy New Year to everybody, all our listener, from us here at SmartList. Happy New Year, everybody. And SmartList is our podcast, Sean. How would you describe it? I would describe it as a lot of talking, and then we're out. But we also have a guest. Oh, that's right. We each bring on a guest that the other two don't know about as a surprise.
祝大家新年快乐，各位听众，来自我们SmartList节目组。新年快乐，大家。SmartList是我们的播客，肖恩。你会怎么描述它？我会把它描述为聊个没完，然后我们就收工。但我们也会请一位嘉宾。哦，对哦。我们每人会带一位另外两人都不知道的神秘嘉宾。
Yeah, that's right. Oh, gosh, I'm so happy you explained it, not Bateman, because that would have been like 40 minutes. Anyway, it's SmartList, and you're about to listen to it, so strap on. Strap in. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList.
对，没错。天哪，我太高兴是你来解释了，贝特曼，因为如果是你的话，得说个40分钟。总之，这就是SmartList，你们马上就要收听了，所以系好安全带。系好。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。
SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. What's your snackin' on, Jay?
SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。杰，你在吃什么零食？
Oh, that's what I do is I put some almonds in my smoothie to give it a little taste. Hey, will, will, will, will. Hey, guys, guys, I've been thinking on a good new opening for the show, and it goes like, hey, I'm Will. And I'm Jason. And I'm Sean. And you're listening to SmartList. SmartList.
哦，我的做法是在奶昔里加点杏仁，让它有点味道。嘿，威尔，威尔，威尔，威尔。嘿，伙计们，伙计们，我一直在想一个节目的精彩新开场，它是这样的，嘿，我是威尔。我是杰森。我是肖恩。欢迎收听SmartList。SmartList。
Do we say SmartList together? Let's say SmartList again. Okay. One, two, three. SmartList. No, you gotta do it, and you're listening, too. Oh, I'm Will. I'm Jason.
我们是一起说SmartList吗？我们再来一遍SmartList。好的。一，二，三。SmartList。不对，你得加上“欢迎收听”那句。哦，我是威尔。我是杰森。
And I'm Sean. And you're listening, too. SmartList. SmartList. Oh, that wasn't together. Why wouldn't you guys? I pulled a hamstring. Hamstring?
我是肖恩。欢迎收听。SmartList。SmartList。哦，刚才没齐。你们怎么不……我拉伤了腿筋。腿筋？
No, an old person thing last night. I have him. I grind my teeth at night. So does my eight-year-old. Do you want to borrow her mouthguard? I have. I have a mouthguard. I have.
不，昨晚搞了个老年人专属的东西。我有。我晚上磨牙。我八岁的女儿也这样。你想借她的咬合护齿吗？我有。我有咬合护齿。我有。
That's where I was going with that. No. You don't need to say that with such surprise. We're not shocked. Okay, okay, good. The senior moment that I had where last night, I'm just falling asleep, but like, oh, damn, I forgot to put my mouthguard in. And I'm looking all over for it in the dark, and I'm looking in my bedroom and looking in
我刚才正要说这个。不用。你没必要表现得这么惊讶。我们又不是被吓到了。好吧，好吧，好。我昨天有个高光时刻，就是快睡着的时候，心想，哦，该死，我忘了戴护齿了。于是我在黑暗中到处找，在我的卧室里找，在……
the bathroom. I go downstairs. I didn't want to wake up the new puppy that we have, because he's just on a schedule. So I'm like, I'll screw it. And I go to bed. I wake up in the morning. It was in my mouth the whole time. Jesus.
浴室里找。我下楼去。我不想吵醒我们新养的小狗，因为他作息很规律。所以我想，管它的。然后我上床睡觉了。早上醒来。它一直在我的嘴里。天哪。
Do you have, do you have a numb jaw? Some people have a numb bottom jaw. Yeah, no, I had some, I had a pain, massive pain in my left jaw, all over my head. Do you seem to have a lot of like sleep blackout type stuff where like you're surprised and stuff happens. You find yourself in the emergency room, like stuff's going on. Scotty doesn't wake up. You've got major injuries.
你，你的下巴有麻木感吗？有些人下巴底部会麻。对，没有，我有一点，我的左下巴剧痛，整个脑袋都在痛。你好像经常有那种睡眠断片的情况，就是你会感到惊讶，然后事情就发生了。你发现自己进了急诊室，诸如此类的事情正在发生。斯科蒂叫不醒。你受了重伤。
What is happening over there? I guess the question is, do you need to move next door to Cedars? Absolutely. Absolutely. It's a great sign. It's not a great sign. Guys, we have a heck of a guest today. We'll see.
那边到底在发生什么？我想问题是，你需要搬到锡安山医疗中心隔壁去住吗？绝对的。绝对的。这可不是个好兆头。这不是个好兆头。伙计们，我们今天有一位重磅嘉宾。走着瞧。
This person, of course, is Canadian. Oh God. By birth. Damn it. They are, they are the pride of McMaster University. One of your favorite universities, Jason and Sean. This is where they teach how to flip burgers? Well, they, they prepare you for life.
这位，当然是加拿大人。哦，天哪。土生土长的。该死。他们是麦克马斯特大学的骄傲。杰森和肖恩，你们最喜欢的大学之一。这就是他们教人怎么翻汉堡的地方吗？嗯，他们，他们为你的人生做准备。
This person is obviously well prepared for life. They took all the knowledge from McMaster University and launched into the rest of their life completely prepared. Not further ado, I'd like to welcome our surprise guest, someone you know and love, and I hope we will know and love even more. Guys, it's Martin Short. Oh my God. Or at least he looks a lot like him.
这个人显然为人生做好了充分的准备。他们吸收了麦克马斯特大学的所有知识，然后带着完全的准备开启了余生。废话不多说，我想欢迎我们的神秘嘉宾，一个你们熟悉并喜爱的人，希望我们以后会更加熟悉并喜爱。伙计们，他就是马丁·肖特！天哪。或者至少他长得非常像他。
Yeah. No, it's me. And it sounds like him. It's me. Oh, Martin. It's Marty Short. Jason. Very happy to have you, sir.
对。不，就是我。听起来也很像他。就是我。哦，马丁。是马蒂·肖特。杰森。非常高兴有你作客，先生。
Oh, so thrilled to be here. How nice of you to do this. Martin. Yeah. Where do you put the accent on the name? Mar or the tin? Tin. Well, Martin.
哦，太高兴能来到这里了。你做这节目真是太好了。马丁。对。你名字的重音放在哪里？Mar还是tin？Tin。好吧，马丁。
Martin. Do you know that I actually truthfully, without any irony or attempt at humor, for many years would say, I've got to download that and realize that, and I, and someone said, why download? And I'd say, why download? I mean, you know, anyway, this can be trim. Hey, I'm thinking of a name for you guys. Let's hear it.
马丁。你知道我其实真的，没有任何讽刺或试图搞笑的意思，多年来一直会说，我得把那个下载下来，然后意识到，我，然后有人说，为什么要下载？我会说，为什么下载？我的意思是，你知道的，总之，这段可以剪掉。嘿，我在想给你们起个组合名。说来听听。
The Maguire Sisters. What are you guys thinking about? I'm so excited you said yes to Will to do this. First of all, I love Will. And can I tell you, Mr. Bateman, that I am so obsessed with your series. I'm blanking on the name. I want to say inbred. I want to say, I want to say inbred, but it's not inbred, but you know the one I mean.
马奎尔姐妹。你们觉得怎么样？我太高兴你答应威尔来做这个了。首先，我爱威尔。我能告诉你吗，贝特曼先生，我对你的系列剧简直着迷透顶。我一时想不起名字了。我想说《乱伦家族》。我想说，我想说《乱伦家族》，但不是这个，不过你知道我指的是哪一个。
I'm telling you honestly, let me get that out of the way. It's just spectacular. Sean's career speaks very little to me, and Will, I think, is working at Endeavor now. But Ozark is an absolute triumph, so congratulations. You're very, very nice. Thank you. You're welcome. Marty Short, the pride of Canada.
说真的，让我先把这个说完。简直绝了。肖恩的职业生涯对我的影响微乎其微，威尔现在好像在Endeavor工作。但《黑钱胜地》绝对是一部里程碑之作，所以恭喜你。你人太好了。谢谢。不客气。马蒂·肖特，加拿大的骄傲。
Oh, I think, I guess, yeah. Fighting out of Hamilton, Ontario. One of the great things, this has been covered a million times, but I would be delinquent if I didn't bring it up. And I've heard you talk about it before, this production of Godspell that you're really your first professional acting gig, is that right, or is that right? Yes, I was still at university. I was going to be a doctor for two years.
哦，我想，我猜，对。从安大略省汉密尔顿走出来。有一件很棒的事，这个已经被报道过无数次了，但如果我不提出来，那就是我的失职了。而且我听你以前谈过，这部《福音》可以说是你真正的第一份专业表演工作，是这样吗，还是说……是的，我当时还在上大学。我本来打算当两年医生。
I was in pre-meds, and then I realized I didn't care about science. I just was a fan of Chad Everett, who was on Medical Center at the time. So I then switched to social work, but didn't really, I just wanted to not have to work so hard. And then in the last semester of my fourth year, they were auditioning the show Godspell, and Eugene Levy said you should audition. And I did, and I got it. But you auditioned for it, you were from Hamilton, and for people who don't know, you were from
我读的是医学预科，后来发现我对科学根本不感兴趣。我只是《医疗中心》里查德·埃弗雷特的粉丝。于是我转到了社会工作专业，但也并没有……我只是想工作不要那么辛苦。然后在我大四的最后一个学期，他们在为音乐剧《福音》试镜，尤金·列维说你应该去试试。我就去了，然后被录取了。但你去试镜时，你是从汉密尔顿来的，对于那些不知道的人，你是从……
Hamilton, the show was in Toronto, that's a 45-minute drive. That's a big move to go from McMaster to all of a sudden auditioning for a real production in Toronto. With a cast, these guys probably don't know who was in the cast. So it was kind of amazing. It was kind of like American Idol, because everyone wanted this show. And Stephen Schwartz, who at that time was 25, he would later write Pippin and Wicked, et cetera.
汉密尔顿来的，演出在多伦多，那得开车45分钟。从麦克马斯特大学突然决定去多伦多参加一个真正的制作试镜，这可是一大步。还有演员阵容，这些家伙可能不知道谁在演员阵容里。所以这有点神奇。这有点像《美国偶像》，因为每个人都想要这个演出。斯蒂芬·施瓦茨当时25岁，他后来写了《皮平正传》和《魔法坏女巫》等等。
And he now had this off-Broadway hit, and they wanted to do it in Toronto. So he came up with the author of the book, and they auditioned like 1,000 people, and I went in and I got a callback. And then at the callback, it was really like in the Masonic Temple in Toronto, people were filling the rafters, supporting their friends. And I guess about 40 people were called back, and through the day, they just kept narrowing it down. And I've told this many times, but I'll tell it again, Gilda Radner got up.
他当时有了这个外百老汇热门剧，他们想在多伦多上演。于是他带着剧本的创作者一起来了，他们试镜了大约1000人，我去了，然后我得到了复试通知。接着在复试时，真的就像在多伦多的共济会神庙里一样，人们挤满了顶棚，来支持他们的朋友。我猜大约有40人被叫去复试，一整天下来，他们不断地筛选。我讲过很多次了，但我还要再讲一遍，吉尔达·拉德纳站了起来。
No one knew who she was. And she was wearing bib overalls, hair and pigtails, and she's saying, dippity-doo-dah, dippity, and I thought, oh, that poor thing, it's like from a home or something, they bust in, and Short stood up and said, you've got it! And he was like, oh, I may have planned incorrectly, because I was singing My Funny Valentine. So you know, I now had to rethink my choices. So anyway, they kept narrowing it down, and they narrowed down to Gilda and Eugene Levy and Andrea Martin, and Victor Garber was Jesus, and Pa Shaffer was May Music Director, because
没有人知道她是谁。她穿着背带裤，扎着发辫，嘴里唱着，dippity-doo-dah, dippity，我想，哦，那可怜的孩子，是从疗养院什么的跑出来的吧，被抓进来了，而肖特站起来说，就是你了！当时他就想，哦，我可能计划得不对，因为我唱的是《我可笑的情人》。所以你知道的，我不得不重新考虑我的选择了。总之，他们不断缩小范围，最后缩减到吉尔达、尤金·列维和安德里亚·马丁，维克多·加伯饰演耶稣，保罗·谢弗是我的音乐总监，因为……
he came and played for his girlfriend, and Stephen Schwartz hated the guy who was playing for people. So he went up to him and said, if I can fire that guy over there and you replace him, will you be musical director? It was all like very out of Judy and Mickey, you know, put on a show. And that's where the hook was set, and you stayed in show business ever since. Your career is so impressively long. I think longevity is truly kind of the gold medal in this business, and you have a big
他是来给女朋友伴奏的，而斯蒂芬·施瓦茨讨厌那个正在给别人伴奏的家伙。于是他走到他面前说，如果我把那边的家伙解雇，由你来取代他，你愿意当音乐总监吗？这一切就像朱迪和米奇的电影一样，你知道的，咱们演个戏吧。从那以后，命运的钩子就咬上了，你从此留在了演艺圈。你的职业生涯长得令人印象深刻。我认为长青在这个行业里绝对相当于金牌，而你有一块又大又肥的。
fat one. God, it is, because if it was based on success, I'd be finished. So wait, but Marty, you know what's so crazy is everybody, I grew up, you were one of my, as you know, and you make me say it to you every time I see you, one of my biggest inspirations growing up. And you know, in my mind, you were on SNL for 15 years, but I don't think a lot of people realize you were only on one season. One season, yes.
天哪，确实如此，因为如果按成功与否来算，我早就完蛋了。等等，但是马蒂，你知道最疯狂的是什么吗，每个人，我是看着……正如你所知，你是我成长过程中的偶像之一，每一次我见到你都会让你对我说这句话。在我的心目中，你在《周六夜现场》待了15年，但我认为很多人并不知道你其实只演了一季。只演了一季，是的。
But you stood out so incredibly as one of the staples of that show in the history of the show. Why do you think that is? Well, I think, you know, Billy Crystal and Christopher Guest and Harris Shearer and I all had a one year contract, because what had happened is it was now, this was the 10th season, 84, 85. And the year before Eddie Murphy had left halfway through, and now it was just up to Joe Piscopo.
但作为该节目历史上的一大支柱，你的表现极其耀眼。你觉得这是为什么呢？嗯，我想，你知道，比利·克里斯托、克里斯托弗·盖斯特、哈里·谢勒和我当时都签了一年的合同，因为当时的情况是，那是第10季，84、85年。而前一年埃迪·墨菲在中途离开，现在只剩下乔·皮斯托波了。
So for some reason they were concerned about the future of the show. And then Joe left and that is why he got in such good shape because he was worried about all the heavy lifting. Well, that's like, that's like Mozart. That's brilliant. Uh huh. But anyway, so then they, so Dick Ebersole, it wasn't Lauren then Dick Ebersole was panicked that the show would be canceled.
所以出于某种原因，他们对节目的未来感到担忧。然后乔也离开了，这就是为什么他身材保持得那么好，因为他担心要挑大梁。嗯，这就像，这就像莫扎特。这太绝了。嗯哼。不过总之，然后他们，所以迪克·埃伯索尔——当时不是洛恩，是迪克·埃伯索尔——惊慌失措，生怕节目被取消。
So he gave the four of us a one year contract. And I think the reason we did so much is that we treated it like doing a special every Saturday as opposed to just being a cast member. I wish I'd said, no, I'll stay as long as you want. And then I would have not panic when I had nothing on Tuesday night. Am I? Would you have wanted to keep going and going and going on that show? No.
于是他给我们四个人一人发了一年合同。我想我们之所以做了那么多，是因为我们把它当作每周一次的特别节目来对待，而不是仅仅当作一个常规演员。我真希望当时能说，不，你想让我留多久我就留多久。那样的话，当我在周二晚上毫无头绪时，我就不会惊慌失措了。我是吗？你当时想在那档节目里一直演下去吗？不。
Was it your, who's, who's choices was your choice? Well, again, I think it's all, it's, I think it's, it was my choice and, and Lauren came back the next year and he's, you know, asked if I would do it. But I just, I had done SCTV for three years. I had a new little baby and I was just like, I was just burned out. And also I put so much pressure on myself every week because you could have a great Saturday night show, feel like a star, feel brilliant. And then by Tuesday afternoon, cause I was right on the show, if you didn't have an idea,
那是你的，到底是谁的选择？好吧，再次说明，我认为这一切，我认为，这是我的选择，而且洛恩第二年回来了，他，你知道的，问我愿不愿意做。但我刚刚，我已经演了三年《SCTV》。我有一个刚出生的小宝宝，我当时就是，我真的是筋疲力尽了。而且我每周给自己施加了太多的压力，因为你可能有一个棒极了的周六晚间节目，感觉自己像个明星，觉得自己聪明绝顶。然后到了周二下午，因为我还要参与写剧本，如果你没有灵感，
you felt like the biggest failure. So it was like final exams every week. But I think if I'd known I was going to hang around there a long time, I would have relaxed and not been so tense. Did you and Lauren know each other from Toronto? Did you guys, had you guys known each other before, like before you came on SNL? Lauren came and saw God's Bell in 73, but I knew Lauren through Gilda. Right.
你就会觉得自己是个彻头彻尾的失败者。所以这就好比每周都要期末考试。但我想如果我知道我要在那里待很久的话，我就会放松下来，不会那么紧张了。你和洛恩在多伦多就认识吗？你们，你们在来《周六夜现场》之前就认识吗？洛恩在1973年看过《福音》，但我跟洛恩是通过吉尔达认识的。对。
So the devil back, this is interesting. So, so you do one year in SNL, Lauren says you want to come back. You say no, you've got a young baby. What's, what's that moment like? Because you know what you could do. You know what SNL is. You could go in there week after week and continue to create characters and continue to write and whatever, maybe for four, five, six years more if you wanted to.
所以剧情反转，这很有趣。所以，所以在《SNL》干了一年，洛恩说你想回来吗？你说不，你有一个年幼的宝宝。那一刻是什么感觉？因为你知道你能做什么。你知道《SNL》是什么。你可以周复一周地去那里继续塑造角色，继续写作，无论如何，如果你想的话，可能还会再干四、五年、六年。
And yet you decide, no, I'm going to go do something else. That's kind of a bold move. I don't know. I think, I think, again, SCTV three years and then that four years. And but I remember going to Lauren's apartment in New York, it's, it's a May of 1985. I have a slight rain man thing of days. And I just don't let him, and I went to Lauren's apartment to discuss this Western three amigos. And but he kept saying, should he go back and what if I went back with him?
然而你决定，不，我要去干别的。这算是个挺大胆的举动。不知道。我想，我想，还是那句话，《SCTV》三年，然后是《SNL》四年。但我记得在1985年5月，我去洛恩在纽约的公寓——我对日期有点像《雨人》那样的强迫症。我就是不让自己忘掉，我去洛恩的公寓讨论那部西部片《三个朋友》。但他一直说，他应该回去吗，如果我和他一起回去会怎么样？
And I said, well, how, how could I do a movie and do serenity live? He said, it's called scheduling. Right. Right. And Marty, you know, when we, I went to your cabin in, uh, Muskoka, Muskoka, Muskoka Lakes. And it's so beautiful and pleasant up there. And we had such a great time and you're one of the most joyous, kind, pleasant people I've ever known and hung out with and my friends with.
我说，好吧，我怎么可能既拍电影又做《周六夜现场》呢？他说，这叫档期管理。对。对。还有马蒂，你知道的，当我们，我去过你在穆斯科卡，穆斯科卡湖的木屋。那里真是又美丽又惬意。我们在那儿度过了美好的时光，你是我所认识、交往和做朋友的人中最快乐、最善良、最亲切的人之一。
And you, you've shared with me this one kind of way you view life and the way you take time for your friends, you take time for your job, you take time for your family, you take, and there's this one thing you know, I'm talking about, you mean the nine categories? Maybe that's what it is. And can you tell what that is? Oh, well, this is when I was like about 28. And it was the first time I, you know, I started working when I was 22 and I just worked all the time.
而且你，你曾和我分享过你看待生活的一种方式，你如何为朋友抽出时间，为工作抽出时间，为家庭抽出时间，你抽出，有一件你知道我在说的事情，你是说那九大类吗？也许就是这个。你能讲讲那是什么吗？哦，好吧，这是在我大约28岁的时候。那是我第一次，你知道的，我22岁开始工作，然后我就一直在工作。
And now for the first time I hit this patch where I remember I kept going down and trying to get to Toronto. Every time I went down to get the subway, the subway was leaving. It didn't matter if I ran toward the subway or walk slowly toward it, it was always leaving. And I thought, I guess when the subway's arriving, that's when I will get another job, but there's a good chance I'll never work again. Now, so this was lasted for about two months, but it was the first time I'd gone through this.
然后现在我第一次遇到了这样一个低谷，我记得我一直往下走，想去坐多伦多地铁。每次我走到地铁口准备坐地铁时，地铁刚开走。不管我是朝着地铁跑过去，还是慢慢走过去，它总是刚好开走。我想，我猜等地铁到站的时候，就是我找到下一份工作的时候了，不过我这辈子再也不能工作的几率也挺大。好吧，所以这持续了大约两个月，但这是我第一次经历这种事。
And then afterwards, and by the end of that year, I realized I'd made more money and had lots of jobs. And I thought, gee, I wish I could have those two months back. I'm not going to let that happen again. So that I thought, wait a second, what if your career was just one of nine courses you took? And so that means if you're not working, if you get an F in your career, you can still get a good GPA by doing well in the other categories like subjects. So the categories were one was self, you know, what's your weight?
然后在那之后，到了那年年底，我意识到我赚了更多钱，而且有很多工作。我想，天哪，我真希望那两个月能重来。我绝不会让这种事再发生。所以我当时想，等一下，如果你的事业只是你选修的九门课程中的一门呢？这意味着如果你没有工作，如果你的事业得了F，你依然可以通过在其他类别或科目上取得好成绩来获得一个不错的GPA。所以这九大类别是：第一类是自我，你知道的，你的体重如何？
Are you working out? Are you in good health? Two is your wife, girlfriend, and kids. And if you have a wife and a girlfriend, you know. You're doing great. You got an A. And then three was your original family, siblings. Four was your friends. Five was finances.
你有在锻炼吗？你身体健康吗？第二类是你的妻子、女友和孩子。如果你既有妻子又有女朋友，你知道的。那你过得太棒了。你能得个A。然后第三类是你的原生家庭、兄弟姐妹。第四类是你的朋友。第五类是财务。
Six was creativity. And then discipline and seven. And then the last one is lifestyle. Like are you having any fun? How did you think of, did you read that? I mean, you just thought of it yourself? No, I just, it just came upon me one day. And then I would actually do it, and I would actually do it like a report card.
第六类是创造力。然后第七类是自律。最后一类是生活方式。比如你过得开心吗？你是怎么想出这个的？你读到过吗？我是说，你自己想出来的吗？不，我只是，有一天它突然降临到我脑海里。然后我真的照做了，我真的把它当成成绩单一样来处理。
Like I'd get myself Christmas grades and finals. Yeah. Oh, you would go back and look through that. That's interesting. Yeah. Well, I would just, I would think that, okay, so this is now horrible. Okay. I got to say that's a D. How can I get an A. Oh, I can be a better friend.
比如我会给自己打圣诞成绩和期末成绩。对。哦，你会回头去翻看那些记录。这很有趣。对。嗯，我就会想，好吧，所以这个现在糟透了。好吧。我得说那是个D。我怎么才能拿个A。哦，我可以做个更好的朋友。
Okay. And I can pull that up to an A. But wouldn't, wouldn't, wouldn't not pulling a good grade in finances pull everything down and potentially out onto the street? Oh, he never pays for dinner. That's how he gets an A. Oh, God. Yeah.
好的。我可以把那个拉高到A。但是，难道，难道，难道在财务上拿不到好成绩不会把一切都拖垮，甚至有可能流落街头吗？哦，他从来不请客吃饭。他就是靠这个拿A的。天哪。对。
Yeah. No, no, you can be very rich in your career of being the dumper. Look at, look at Sean. No, Sean, Sean is spiritually broken for sure. Of course. Sure. Can I, can I close the loop on the report card thing with a semi-serious question here? Yeah.
对，不，不，你在当“甩手掌柜”的事业上可以非常富有。看看肖恩。不，肖恩在精神上绝对是崩溃的。当然。当然。我能用一个半严肃的问题来为这个成绩单的话题做个结语吗？可以。
What is your highest grade and your lowest grade right now in your, in your nine channels? I also color code my weight. Got it. Based on the John Ashcroft alert system. So like the, the, the, the lowest you'd ever be is in your green zone. And then the next is your blue zone. And that's kind of like where you want it to be. And then, then there's the yellow zone, then there's the orange zone, and then there's
在你目前的九大通道里，你得到过最高的分数和最低的分数分别是什么？我还会根据体重来进行颜色编码。明白了。根据约翰·阿什克罗夫特警戒系统。所以，比如说，你可能達到的最低状态是在绿色区域。然后接下来是蓝色区域。那差不多就是你希望呆的地方。然后，还有黄色区域，橙色区域，还有……
the red zone. I'm in pig purple. So for that, which is beyond red, that's, so I would say that I would have to therefore give category one, um, about my health is great. I'm swimming every day, but I, it's, it's, it's not beautiful naked. So I would give myself a B minus there. Purely on just, I'm seven pounds overweight. Seven.
红色区域。我是“猪肝紫”。对于那种情况，也就是超越了红色，所以我会说，因此我不得不给第一类，关于我的健康的打分……我的健康状况很好。我每天都在游泳，但是，它，它，它光着身子并不好看。所以我会在那里给自己一个B减。纯粹是因为，我超重了七磅。七磅。
So, so when you take a nude selfie, you're not. Which I will. And send you some. Right. Of course. That's why. Well, we need to promote the podcast. Yeah.
所以，所以当你拍自拍裸照时，你并不是……我会的。而且还会发一些给你。好啊。当然。这就是为什么。好吧，我们需要宣传播客。对。
Got it up. All right. So, so, so health, so health is, is a B. So would that be your highest grade? No, I think, I think, uh, I've never been hotter at showbiz. I would say, um, well, lifestyle is always an A. I have a good life. You know what I mean? Yeah. I, I, I get out, um, creativity, that's a D. Uh, discipline is just what's lower
好极了。好，所以，所以健康，所以健康是B。那会是你的最高分吗？不，我想，我想，我在秀场上从没这么火过。我会说，嗯，生活方式一直都是A。我过着好日子。你知道我的意思吗？对。我，我经常出去，嗯，创造力，那是D。嗯，自律简直比“不及格”还要……
than enough. But I, I definitely, I'm a good friend. I've got lots of money. So if you have lots of money, like you've got Ozark money. Yeah. And then the friends are just, they take care of themselves with that. Right. Yeah.
更低。不过我，我绝对是个好朋友。我有很多钱。所以如果你有很多钱，比如你拥有《黑钱胜地》赚来的钱。对。然后朋友们自然就会因此而聚拢过来。对。对。
Um, the discipline, you strike me as a very disciplined person. You're saying you're not. I am. I am. I'm just trying to be self-effacing. Yeah. Cause you know, there's everyone saying, I'm so great. I feel the fool.
嗯，至于自律，你在我看来是一个极其自律的人。你却说你不是。我是。我是。我只是想表现得谦虚一点。对。因为你知道，如果每个人都说，我太棒了，我会觉得自己像个傻子。
I don't know that that comes through talk as much as it visual aid. If, Sean, if you could see him right now. He's, he's a, uh, a picture of discipline. So in anticipation of Marty being here today, I went and did the thing that I like to do about once every six months, which is watch this scene from Clifford, watch, watch a scene from Clifford, um, with, uh, with Charles Groton and, um, and Marty, you play a boy of 12. Is that right?
我不知道这种感觉通过谈话传达出来，是不是比通过视觉辅助更明显。肖恩，如果你现在能看到他。他，他就是，一个自律的化身。所以为了迎接马蒂今天到来，我特意去做了我大概每六个月做一次的事情，那就是看电影《小鬼当街》里的一个片段，看，看《小鬼当街》里的一段，里面有查尔斯·格罗登，还有，还有马蒂，你演一个12岁的男孩。是这样吗？
10. And then I thought it would be very, very important that he was prepubescent. Right. Sorry. Sorry. He's 10. He's obsessed with dinosaurs. Yes.
10岁。然后我觉得让他在青春期之前非常非常重要。对不起。对不起。他10岁。他迷恋恐龙。是的。
And there's a scene. Mitch Hurwitz and I have watched, I'm going to say a thousand times, I'm just going to take the, I'm going to take the ender on it because there's a scene where Groton says to you, I'm going to tell you something. Don't touch the, he keeps saying, don't touch the dinosaur and you keep subtly reaching your hand for the dinosaur. And he's like, leave it alone and he takes it away and he puts it in his pocket because you won't stop touching it.
有一个场景。米奇·赫威茨和我看了，我可以说有一千遍，我打算把这个夸张的说法坐实，因为里面有一个场景，格罗登对你说，我要告诉你一件事。别碰那个，他不停地说，别碰那只恐龙，而你却一直悄悄把手伸向恐龙。然后他说，别碰它，把它拿开，放进自己的口袋里，因为你总是忍不住要摸。
Yes, I'm going to go and I'm going to tell her this and that. Look at me. Look at me like a boy. Starts to contort his face to look at him because he says, look at me like a human boy. Well, he gets there. He first says boy, but then he says, and then you control your face and he goes, look at me like a human boy. Does this look where he tries, it's a 10 year old trying to figure out what a, it's one
对，我要去，我要去告诉她这个和那个。看着我。像个男孩一样看着我。开始扭曲面部表情看着他，因为他说，像一个真正的人类男孩一样看着我。好吧，他做到了。他先是说“男孩”，但随后他说，然后你控制住自己的面部表情，他说，像一个真正的人类男孩一样看着我。你看这个地方，他试着，这是一个10岁的孩子在试图弄清楚什么是……这是我……
of my favorite moments I've ever, I think. Thank you, William. Oh God. It's like, that's my, that's my moment that I wish that I could have. And I think if I had a piece of talent, I'd do that. Marty, tell us what Steve Martin, when he introduces the movie Clifford to the audience. Oh yes. He says, he says, Marty was in a film, I'm telling a story, he says, what's your most
有史以来最喜欢的时刻之一，我想。谢谢你，威廉。天哪。这就像是，这是我梦寐以求的时刻。我想如果我有一点点天赋，我也会这么做。马蒂，给我们讲讲史蒂夫·马丁在向观众介绍电影《小鬼当街》时是怎么说的。哦，是的。他说，他说，马蒂曾参演过一部电影，我讲个故事，他说，你最尴尬的事情是什么？我说，嗯，1990年，我拍了一部叫《小鬼当街》的电影，你知道，观众听到这会心一笑。
embarrassing thing? I said, well, in 1990, I made a film called Clifford and you know, you'll get this from the audience. And he said, see the people that applauded, remember that movie. And the people that didn't applaud, also remember that. But I'll bet you'll say, cause I was also one of the luckiest guys in the world to work with Charles Groden. I'll bet you'll say the greatest thing about that movie was working with, with, with Chuck
他说，看那些鼓掌的人，他们还记得那部电影。而那些没鼓掌的人，也同样记得。但我敢打赌你会说，因为我也是世界上最幸运能与查尔斯·格罗登合作的人之一。我敢打赌你会说那部电影最棒的事就是能与查克·格罗登合作。
Groden. He was so fantastic and so funny. I love that guy. Oh my God, I adored him. He was fabulous. He was so funny and smart and hip and all the stories. Is he retired? Yeah.
他太棒了，太有趣了。我太喜欢那家伙了。天哪，我崇拜他。他棒极了。他那么有趣、聪明、时髦，还有那些故事。他退休了吗？是的。
I don't know. I don't know. He still does stuff. He was spending a lot of time championing people who are incarcerated without cause or it does benefits for that. Yeah. Yeah. He's really, really passionate about that.
我不知道。我不知道。他还在做一些事。他花了很多时间为那些被无辜关押的人奔走呼吁，或者为之举办慈善活动。对。对。他对那个真的非常非常热忱。
And his comfortable living, you know, gorgeous mansion in Connecticut. He's, he's, he's done it. You know, it reminds me, it's Sean, you saying about Steve, I remember being at dinner one time with you guys and Steve told a funny story and people laughed and he goes, I tell you, man, if you don't get an agent after that story, I don't know. Like, you're the only person I know who can, who consistently, you know, make fun of him and he loves it more than anything. God, he loves it.
而且他过着舒适的生活，你知道的，在康涅狄格州有一栋华丽的豪宅。他，他，他做到了。你知道，这让我想起，肖恩，你刚才说史蒂夫的事，我记得有一次和你们一起吃晚饭，史蒂夫讲了一个好笑的故事，大家笑了，他说，我告诉你，伙计，如果听了这故事你还找不到经纪人，那我可就不知道了。就像，你是我认识的唯一一个能够，能够经常，你知道的，取笑他而他却比什么都高兴的人。天哪，他太喜欢了。
Yeah, he does. He has never at any time, you know, cause we will do interviews together cause we used to do live shows. And we would, they'd always said, do you guys insult each other? Do you ever go too far? And we realized both that we've never, ever, ever gone too far and never had a fight, I don't think. In fact, I know.
对，他确实如此。他从来没有在任何时候，你知道的，因为我们经常一起接受采访，因为我们以前做过现场演出。他们总会问，你们会互相侮辱吗？你们会过火吗？而我们都意识到，我们从来、从来、从来没有过火，而且我觉得我们从来没有吵过架。事实上，我知道。
And I think it's that he believes that it would be impossible for me to ever say anything that truly was meant to hurt him. He just does not in his computer. That's sweet. Yeah. He just doesn't think that you have that mean bone in your body. Is that right? So anything that's kind of on the line, he just gives you the benefit of the doubt?
而且我认为这是因为他坚信，我绝不可能说出任何真正意在伤害他的话。这种概念根本不在他的程序里。太甜了。对。他就是觉得你骨子里没有那种刻薄的基因。是这样吗？所以任何踩在边缘的话，他都会选择对你网开一面？
Absolutely. Although Dave Foley from Kids in the Hall once said to me about Jiminy Glick, he said, you have finally created a character who's as mean as you really are in life. Speaking of that, you know, that is one of the most iconic characters of all time. I mean, it is, it is one of the most incredible, it's endlessly funny. Well, Ed Grimly is pretty high up there. And Ed Grimly. Yeah, they're all.
绝对的。虽然《哈林疯狂》的戴夫·弗利曾对我说过关于吉米·格利克的评价，他说，你终于创造出了一个和你生活中一样刻薄的角色。说到这个，你知道的，那是史上最具标志性的角色之一。我的意思是，它是，它是最不可思议的之一，有着无穷的笑点。嗯，埃德·格林利也算名列前茅。还有埃德·格林利。是的，他们都是。
What about Uncle Jack? Uncle Jack from Arrested Development. Marty, who was the best Jiminy Glick interview and who was the worst? Well, I can't say who the worst was. That would be mean. But the best, I don't know, they were all, I don't even think of anyone as, I remember with John Lovitz, I fell asleep in the middle of me interviewing. He was answering a question.
还有杰克叔叔呢？《发展受阻》里的杰克叔叔。马蒂，谁是吉米·格利克采访过最好的嘉宾，谁又是最差的？嗯，我不能说谁是最差的。那样太刻薄了。但最好的，我不知道，他们都是，我甚至不觉得有谁是……我记得和约翰·洛维茨在一起时，我在采访他的时候睡着了。他当时正在回答问题。
In the middle of asking a question. I asked him a question. He, as he was answering, I fell asleep and fell out of the chair, out of the ground. And then, I remember saying to Steven Spielberg, what are you going to do, the big one, the one that connects the people? But I told Steven, he's an old friend of mine, I said, at one point, I'm going to, this is the one before we start, I said, I'm going to ask you a question to define your kind of filmmaking.
在我提问的过程中。我问了他一个问题。他在回答的过程中，我睡着了，从椅子上摔了下去，摔在地上。然后，我记得我对史蒂夫·斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格说，你要怎么拍，那个宏大的、能把人们联系在一起的电影？但我告诉史蒂夫，他是我多年的老朋友，我说，在某个时刻，我，这是开始之前说的，我说，我要问你一个问题来定义你的电影风格。
And he said, wow, that's, I said, no, no, it will be all fine. And so he, he looked off and as I'm asking the question, I mean, I asked him what about his career and filmmaking and he starts going on about it. And as he's looking off, I slid out of the chair and the camera followed me over to the craft service table. And I got a million gummy bears and four donuts and then crawled back and the camera's just on me. And then I sit in the chair and he's saying, but you know, I think Fellini, I didn't, that
他说，哇，那是，我说，不，不，一切都会很好的。所以他，他把视线移开，当我在问问题时——我是说，我问他关于他的职业生涯和电影制作，他开始滔滔不绝地讲起来。当他把视线移开时，我从椅子上滑了下去，摄像机跟着我移到了自助餐桌旁。我拿了一百万颗小熊软糖和四个甜甜圈，然后又爬了回去，而摄像机一直对着我。然后我坐回椅子上，他说，但你知道，我认为费里尼，我没有……那不是很棒吗？现在，我喜欢这个答案。
wonderful. Now, I love the answer to this. But my favorite line, I must admit, was to Mel Brooks when I said, what's your big beef with the Nazis? So he always said it like, was he anti-Semitic? You didn't quite know. He wasn't, of course. So you mentioned before that you talked to Lauren about Three Amigos.
不过我必须承认，我最喜欢的一句台词是对梅尔·布鲁克斯说的，当时我问，你跟纳粹到底有什么深仇大恨？所以他总是这么问，就好像他是反犹太主义者吗？你根本无从得知。他当然不是。所以你之前提到过，你和洛恩谈过《三个朋友》。
Yes. A film that you did end up making, of course. Yes. And you wrote as well. Is that true? No, no, no, no. It was written by Steve Martin, Lauren and Randy Newman. And is that the first time you met Steve on that movie?
是的。一部你最终拍了的电影，当然。是的。而且你还参与了编剧，是这样吗？不，不，不，不。那是斯蒂芬·马丁、洛恩和兰迪·尼曼写的。那是你在这部电影里第一次见到史蒂夫吗？
Uh-huh. Wait a minute. Lauren Michaels and Randy Newman were two of the three writers? Yes, I am. Has either one of them ever written anything before or since? Well, Lauren started off as a writer. He wrote for, you know, the Phyllis Diller sitcom. He wrote for, he wrote a lot of things.
嗯哼。等一下。洛恩·迈克尔斯和兰迪·尼曼是三位编剧中的两位？是的，我是。他们俩以前或以后还写过别的东西吗？嗯，洛恩一开始是个编剧。他为，你知道的，菲利斯·迪勒的情景喜剧写过剧本。他写过，他写过很多东西。
Paul Simon specials. And Randy Newman. And Randy, well, you know, it was a musical. So Randy, but Randy came up with funny things. I think his singing bush was his idea. You know, they would get together the three of them and, you know, meet for lunch and then drink some wine and write. Would you, so that was the first time you met Steve.
保罗·西蒙的特别节目。还有兰迪·尼曼。还有兰迪，嗯，你知道的，那是一部音乐剧。所以兰迪，不过兰迪想出了很多有趣的点子。我想他的“会唱歌的灌木”就是他的主意。你知道的，他们三个会聚在一起，你知道的，碰面吃午饭，然后喝点酒，写剧本。你会，所以那是你第一次见到史蒂夫。
Was that like kind of love at first sight for you guys? Well, I didn't, you know, I went to his after my dinner with Lauren in May of 85, May of 85, I went to, um, then I'm back in LA and I went to Steve's house to pick up a script for three amigos. And I'd never met him. I was excited to meet him, you know, obviously. And I went into his house and it was his old house in Bedford Drive. And there was just, I could, everywhere I looked, there was a Picasso, it was a, you
你们俩当时算是一见钟情吗？嗯，我没有，你知道的，我在85年5月与洛恩共进晚餐之后，85年5月，我去了，嗯，然后我回到了洛杉矶，我去了史蒂夫的家去拿《三个朋友》的剧本。我以前从未见过他。能见到他我很兴奋，显然如此。我走进他的房子，那是他在贝德福德大道的老房子。到处都是，我无论看向哪里，都能看到毕加索，那是一个，你知道的，霍珀。我对他说，你怎么能这么富有，因为我看过你的作品。他真的笑了。然后他说，你能把剧本交给马丁·肖特吗？从那一刻起，这就是一场浪漫的爱情。是的。太棒了。我可以深入探讨一下《雨人》那个话题吗？
know, a hopper. And I said to him, how did you get this rich because I've seen your work. And he really laughed. And then he said, can you give the script to Martin Short? And from that moment on, it was a love affair. Yes. That's great. Can I go deep on the Rain Man thing?
那里有什么东西吗？比如，它不仅仅局限于日期回忆？比如你记台词也这么厉害吗？台词还算不错，但主要是关于日期的。我记得，我没有，你知道的，像玛丽·露·亨纳那样拥有那种能力。那叫H·萨姆。好吧。事实上，我知道我没有，因为有一次我对某人说，你知道，我有那种H·萨姆，你知道的，像玛丽·露，嗯，就像，你知道的，叫什么名字来着？所以我知道我没有，不过，我确实，玛丽，玛丽·露·亨纳，她是有史以来最伟大的女性之一。所以她有一个广播节目，她，我们当时在聊天，她说，你还记得，嗯，我当时在演那部很快就被砍掉的剧《合伙人》，而她当时在演《出租车》。那是吉姆·布鲁克斯的两部剧。所以我第一次见到她就是那时候。但在那年年底，我们去参加金球奖，她说，你还记得谁坐在我们桌上吗？因为她说，她能记得自己穿了什么裙子，吃了什么。
Is there something there? Like, is it, does it extend beyond date recall? Like, do you remember Lines really well? Lines are pretty good, but really about dates. And I remember, I don't have it, you know, like Mary Lou Henner has it. That's called H. Sam. Okay. In fact, I know I don't, because one time I was saying to someone, you know, I have
哇。我说，嗯，我记得有我的妻子南茜。她说，对，你当时和约翰·特拉沃尔塔坐在一起。她说是的。还有谁坐在桌上？我说，我，我记不清了。
that kind of H. Sam, you know, like Mary Lou, uh, like, you know, what's her name? So I knew that it wasn't, but, but I did Mary, Mary Lou, Mary Lou Henner, who's one of the great women of all time. So she had a radio show and she, uh, we were talking and she said, do you remember, um, I was doing this show, The Associates that got quickly cast and she was doing taxi. And it was Jim Brooks, both his shows. So that's when I first met her. But the end of that year, we went to the Golden Globes and I, she said, do you remember who
史蒂夫·斯皮尔伯格。我从来没见过他。出于某种原因，我记不起史蒂夫了。所以她literally记得她生活中的每一个细节和情感。那才是真正的H·萨姆。你也能记住日期吗？用那种方式？她什么都记得。
was at our table? Cause she said, she can remember what the dress she wore and what she ate. Wow. And I said, well, I remember it was my wife, Nancy. She said, yeah, and you were with John Travolta. She said, yeah. And who else was at the table? I said, I, I can't remember.
我能记住，比如我会对我的妻子说，你觉得我们是什么时候第一次去罗马的？她会说，我不知道，88年，91年。我能精确到月份和年份。所以我能做到这一点。你知道这是为什么吗？是因为，是因为，是因为在一个有四季的地方长大吗？因为在洛杉矶这里，每个月都像是四月。你知道我其实是怎么想的吗？
Steven Spielberg. I never met him. For some reason, I couldn't remember Steve. So she literally remembers every detail and emotion of her life. That's a real H. Sam. Did you remember dates too? In that way? She remembers everything.
我觉得部分原因是我把它等同于我当时在做什么工作，因为我从来没有做什么长期的事情。我想我只是能记住那些能帮到忙的事情。而且四季确实有帮助。你喜欢这种没有稳定工作、没有稳定收入的生活吗？就是那种在这个行业里的状态？如果你这一年过得特别好，你实际上会被解雇六次，你知道的，你会接到好几份工作。
I can remember, like I would say to my wife, when, when do you think we first went to Rome? She'd say, I don't know, 88, 91. I could tell you the month and the year. So I can do that. Do you know why that is? Is it, is it, is it based on growing up in a, in a place that, that has seasons? Cause like out here in LA at like every month is April. Do you know what I actually think?
你喜欢这个行业的这种状态，还是说，你其实是一个更偏爱稳定、常规和可预测性的人？杰森的意思是，你喜欢你职业生涯中的什么？没有工作吗？其实我是在自我剖析。好吧，我不知道，这是，这是，我猜有优点也有缺点。你不会被困在任何事情里，但有时你会觉得，你知道，我不知道。这对我来说一直很神奇，在我的职业生涯中。
I think a part of it is I equate it to what I was doing and what I was working and because I was never like in a long run, anything. I think I just can remember that helps anyway. And I think seasons do help. And do you like that not having a steady, a steady job that, that, that thing that is in this business? Like if you have a really good year, you get effectively fired six times, you know, you get multiple jobs.
我其实从来没有过很多一开始就很成功的作品。它们后来之所以成功，你知道的，要么是通过DVD，要么是通过重播。但当时，你知道的，我拍了一部电影叫《惊异大奇航》，那是斯皮尔伯格的片子。我们以为它会是全世界最大的热门片，结果根本没人看。但现在人们走过来会说，哦，然后他们听到那部电影当年上映时没火会感到震惊。所以，你知道的，每个人都有各种各样的作品。但你一直都很自信，坚信总会有属于你的空间，坚信在这个行业里总会有你能占据的一席之地，无论是……
Do you like that about this, about this business or, or are you somebody that, that, that prefers stability and routine and predictability? I guess what Jason's saying is that what you like about your career, not having work? I'm analyzing myself actually. Well I, I don't know. It's, it's, it's, I guess there's pluses and negatives. You're not stuck in anything, but at times you feel like, you know, I don't know. It's always been, it was amazing to me in my career.
我确实没有想过，哦，看来你不行了。我确实有那种奇怪的自信。我想我是家里五个孩子中最小的，每个人都彼此相爱，每个人，你知道的，都把我抱起来背在背上，我是最可爱的，我想这种自信支撑了我的一生。但是，而且也正如我们之前讨论过的，这一点我非常钦佩，并且也尽我所能地去模仿。
I never, I really never had a lot of successful things. They became successful, you know, either through DVD or, or, or replay of it. But at the time, you know, I made a film interspace that was Spielberg. We thought it was going to be the greatest hit in the world and it no one saw. But now people go up and say, oh, and they're stunned to think that that didn't open at the time. So, you know, you have, everyone has those all over the place. But were you always confident that there would be a space for you, that there would be, there
就是那种理念，你喜欢有这九大类，但同时，你不会把作为个人的幸福感死死拴在你所从事的工作上，你拥有如此丰富的生活。我的意思是，真心实意地说，就像你，你休假三个月，去穆斯科卡，花时间陪伴家人，你，那差不多就是你衡量成功的标准，我这样理解对吗？我想是的。对。
would be a, a lane somewhere in the business that you could occupy, whether. I did, I did kind of not think, oh, I guess you're no good. I did have that weird confidence. I think I was the youngest of five kids and everyone loved each other and everyone, you know, picked me up and carried me and I was the cutest and I think that carried me throughout my life. But, but, and also kind of what we talked about before, which I really admire and try to do as well as much as I can.
那又回到了九大类，你知道的，你不能把你的，你不能把你的，你知道的，所有的分数都只放在第六类“事业”上。但我，我想，是的，我总是记得读到过约翰·保罗·盖蒂三世在19岁时被绑架，他们割下他的耳朵寄给他的祖父，而他说，我不会付赎金的。好吧，对这两个人来说，无论对那个被绑架的孩子还是那个刻薄的祖父来说，这都不是一个成功的人生。好吧，关于你，一直以来最激励我的一件事就是那种自信。
Is that idea that you like having the nine categories, but also you put, you don't tether your happiness as a person to what you're necessarily doing work wise, you have such a full life. And I mean, that's in all earnestness, like you, you take three months off, you go up to Miss Coco, you spend time with family, you, that, that's kind of your measure of success I'm gathering. I think so. Yeah.
我和你谈过很多次这个，但就像是，你知道的，我认为每个人都在追求，每个人在这个行业里跑来跑去都那么缺乏安全感，哦天哪，我的下一份工作在哪里？我表现得怎么样？人们会喜欢我吗，所有这些事情，但你似乎完全没有这些。为什么会这样呢？就像你，你的自信一直支撑着你前行。你根本不在乎这个行业里其他人所在乎的那些寻常事。
That, that's back to the nine categories, you know, but you can't just put your, you can't put your, you know, your only marks in category six career. But I, I think that, yeah, I always remember reading about John Paul Getty, the third was kidnapped at 19 and is, they cut his ear off and sent it to his grandfather and he said, I'm not paying. Well, that's not a successful life for either one, for either one, for, for the Banco kid or the mean grandfather. Well, one of the things that, that's always been so inspiring to me about you is the confidence
这，这回到了那九大类别，你知道，但你不能只是把你的，你不能把你的，你知道，你唯一的得分放在第六类“事业”上。但我，我认为，是的，我一直记得读到过保罗·盖蒂三世，他19岁时被绑架了，他们割下他的耳朵送给他的祖父，而他说，我不会付赎金。好吧，这对两边来说都不是成功的人生，不管是对于那个被绑架的孩子还是那个吝啬的祖父。嗯，关于你，一直以来让我觉得最受启发的一件事就是自信
thing. And I talked to you about that a lot, but it's like, you know, I think everybody aspires and the, everybody who runs around this business so insecure, oh my God, where's my next job? How am I coming off? Well people like me, all those things, but you don't seem to have any of those things. And why is that? Like you, you are, your confidence just carries you through. You don't care about the usual things that other people in this business care about.
这件事。我经常和你聊起这个，但这就好像是，你知道，我认为每个人都有所向往，而这个圈子里跑来跑去的人都那么没有安全感，天哪，我的下一份工作在哪里？我给别人留下了什么印象？人们会喜欢我吗，诸如此类的事情，但你似乎完全没有这些烦恼。这是为什么呢？就像你，你的自信支撑着你度过一切。你根本不在乎这个圈子里其他人所在意的那些寻常事物。
Well, thanks, Sean. I think that for me, you know, it's, you know, talk to me, sorry. He has another question for you, but it's not that. Is that the doorbell at your castle? That is, that's my, that's my clock ringing the chime. I forgot. I used to do Catherine Hepburn. You know, I did a movie the week with her.
好吧，谢谢，肖恩。我觉得对我来说，你知道，这，你知道，跟我说，抱歉。他还有个问题要问你，不过不是那个。那是你城堡的门铃吗？那是，那是我的，那是我的时钟在响。我忘了。我以前模仿过凯瑟琳·赫本。你知道的，我和她一起拍过一周的电影。
You did? I did. Yeah. It was a, I think in like the early nineties on CBS, one of her last jobs, I played her driver. It was like a driving Miss Daisy type of, type of thing. It was, it was awesome. Anyway, I, I, not my interview.
你拍过？拍过。是的。那是，我想大约在九十年代初的哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS），那是她最后的工作之一，我演她的司机。有点像《为黛西小姐开车》那种类型的。太棒了。不管怎样，我，我，不是我的采访。
Yeah. Why are you crying? She was so crying to me. Yeah. You got kind of, I call it a bad acting choke in your throat. I call it. We were talking about confidence. I don't know.
对。你为什么在哭？她简直把我弄哭了。对。你有点，我称之为喉咙里卡着一股“烂演技的哽咽”。我管这叫。我们在谈论自信。我不知道。
I think, well, wait a second, Sean, wouldn't you say of yourself, Sean? Yeah. Do you ever go and say, I guess I don't have any talent and I am not worthy? I don't think you do. And if you don't, why? No. Yeah. I don't know.
我想，等一下，肖恩，难道你不会这么评价你自己吗，肖恩？是的。你有没有过这种想法：我猜我没有什么才华，我不配？我觉得你不会。如果你不会，为什么？没有。是的。我不知道。
Yeah. No. I think I have something to offer, but it's just the way that you don't hold on to things, I think. You don't hold on to things. You don't hold on. You don't have grudges. I feel like it seems like you can just move on from failure after failure.
对。没有。我觉得我有什么东西可以奉献，但只是那种你不会对事情念念不忘的方式，我觉得。你不会对事情念念不忘。你不会抓着不放。你不会记仇。我觉得好像你能够从一个又一个的失败中走出来。
No. It seems like, it seems like you can just move on from things that work and things that don't work. I wonder why that is. I truly, and I mean that sincerely, is that, is that DNA or is that the way you're raised or is, what do you think that is? Because I don't know. This, this will sound very LA, but what's your sign?
不。感觉好像，感觉好像你能够从管用和不管用的事情中走出来。我在想这是为什么。我真心实意地问，这，这是DNA还是你的成长环境，或者，你觉得这是什么？因为我不知道。这，这听起来很洛杉矶，但你是什么星座？
Aries. Yeah. I'm going to take that to my wife. Well, let me ask this then, conversely, what is the thing or things that make you uneasy or insecure or unsure? Well, I don't think there's many things that make me feel those things. I mean, I would be unhappy if there's family issues and people are not well or friends are sad.
白羊座。对。我要把这个拿去告诉我太太。好吧，那我反过来问，是什么事情或哪些事情让你感到不安、缺乏安全感或不确定？嗯，我觉得没多少事情能让我有这种感觉。我的意思是，如果有家庭问题，有人生病了，或者朋友难过，我会不开心的。
That makes me sad. I don't really think at this stage of my life that, that I feel insecure about many things because as you get older, you know, I'm 70 now. You don't sit back and go, oh my God, they better like me. You have the body of a 68 year old though. Thank you so much. You know what you, you know what you never hear any time that your name comes up. I've never heard anybody say, boy, that guy's a jerk.
这会让我难过。在我人生的这个阶段，我真的不觉得，我对很多事情感到没有安全感，因为随着年龄的增长，你知道，我现在70岁了。你不会坐在那儿想，哦天哪，他们最好喜欢我。不过你有着一副68岁好身材。非常感谢。你知道你，你知道你在任何时候听到你的名字时绝不会听到什么吗。我从来没听任何人说过，天哪，那家伙是个混蛋。
Yeah. Not once. And that's probably part of it, I mean, is that, yeah, you're, you have a, well, I haven't heard, I've never heard that the two of you were jerks. Well, I'm just, I don't know who, yeah, I get it. I won't say. I get it. I get it.
对。一次也没有。这大概也是原因之一吧，我是说，是的，你，你有一个，嗯，我没听过，我从来没听说你们俩是混蛋。好吧，我只是，我不知道谁，好吧，我懂了。我不说了。我懂了。我懂了。
Oh, by the way, one of the funniest thing that still makes me laugh, you know, when we did a recipe development, we did a lot of improvise. And what I loved about doing that show reminded me of doing SCTV because that's what we used to do. And we'd go to the monitor and look at it, then we'd come back, you know, and change things and make sure it was kept adding things. But we had this big strong guy who had to carry me around because I didn't have the use of my legs.
哦，顺便说一句，至今仍让我捧腹大笑的最搞笑的事情之一，你知道，当我们做《富家穷路》时，我们做了很多即兴表演。我喜欢那个节目的一点是，它让我想起了做《SCTV》的日子，因为我们以前就是那样做的。我们会去监视器前看，然后回来，你知道，改变一些事情，确保不断加入新的东西。但我们有个身材魁梧的家伙，他不得不把我抱来抱去，因为我的腿不能动。
I was playing this character on the back and we kept adding things. And at one point we was a break and I saw when he was crying because we'd worn him out. I mean, his muscles like this, but they were burned out because we had added so much. And then I remember another time where we would just play around with tapes and at one time Jason is telling a story and I'm his uncle and I just collapsed right into your crotch. And you just kept talking, but like a slow tree falling over because you have no, no use of your, of your core muscles or your legs at all.
我当时在演那个后背的角色，我们不断加入新东西。有一次在休息时，我看到他在哭，因为我们把他累垮了。我是说，他的肌肉就像这样，但都累瘫了，因为我们加了太多东西。然后我记得还有一次，我们只是在胡闹磁带，有一次杰森在讲故事，我是他的叔叔，我直接瘫倒在你的裆部。而你却一直在讲话，就像一棵缓慢倒下的树，因为你的核心肌肉或你的腿完全没有任何作用。
So if you're not perfectly centered over your, over your hips, you'll just slowly fall over and, and my lap is in your way. Yeah. And I just kept talking like that. Jason doesn't flinch. If somebody goes to his crotch, he will not flinch. That is, that is a dead area for me too. I wasn't aware you were down there.
所以如果你没有完美地把重心放在你的臀部正上方，你就会慢慢倒下去，而我的大腿正挡着你。对。然后我就一直那样说话。杰森连眼睛都不眨一下。如果有人倒向他的裆部，他眼皮都不会眨一下。对我也一样，那是我的死角。我当时都不知道你在下面。
Were you, were you, did you know anything about the show when Mitch asked you to do it? No way. You watched it? No, but we got back from those who had that it was lots of fun. And why did you say yes? Did you know, did you know Mitch? No, I didn't know Mitch and I had watched the rest of the battle.
你，你，米奇邀请你拍那个节目的时候，你对它了解多少？绝不可能。你看过吗？没有，但我们从看过的人那里听说这非常有趣。那你为什么答应？你认识，你认识米奇吗？不，我不认识米奇，我当时看过《富家穷路》。
It was a massive fan. Oh man. I was. I remember us was such a, when we heard that you were coming to do this show, that was like a, such a pinch me moment. I was a mess. Yeah. I remember, I remember shooting in the beach.
我是个超级粉丝。天哪。我是。我记得当我们听说你要来做这个节目时，那简直是一个“掐掐我吧”的时刻。我当时一团糟。对。我记得，我记得在海滩上拍摄。
I'm duct taped to a horse and vomiting. And then I see this woman waving her eyes, go, muddy, muddy, and it was lies. Do you think I'm going to say no to that show? No, I love that show. I'd watch, I'd watch it right from the beginning. It's not true. It's a huge fan of recent development. It's hilarious.
我被用胶带绑在马背上呕吐。然后我看到这个女人挥舞着眼睛，喊着，玛蒂，玛蒂，那是莱斯（Lies）。你觉得我会对那个节目说不吗？不，我喜欢那个节目。我看了，我从头到尾都在看。这不是真的。他是《富家穷路》的超级粉丝。太搞笑了。
Marty, can I ask you the question that, that gets asked me, I'm sure you've been asked a million times. It's kind of one of those annoying questions they say, what is it about Canada that produces so many funny people? It's true though. What is it like for people who aren't from there, which is the world? What, what is it about? Have you been asked that a thousand times in your life?
玛蒂，我能问你那个别人经常问我的问题吗？我确信你也被人问过一百万次了。这算是个那种让人烦恼的问题，他们说，加拿大到底有什么魔力，能产出这么多搞笑的人？不过这是真的。对于那些不是从那里来的人——也就是全世界——来说，这是什么样的？这是，这到底是怎么回事？你这辈子被问过一千次了吗？
A million times. And I used to think it was a really silly question because, you know, the arts have no border, but then as people just kept coming and kept, you know, and then there was Mike Myers and then there was Phil Hartman, there's you, and there's Seth, Rogan, and it's endless. Jim Carrey. And it continues. Jim Carrey, yes. And not even talking about Catherine and Andrea and all these geniuses.
一百万次。我以前觉得这是个非常愚蠢的问题，因为，你知道，艺术没有国界，但后来随着人们不断涌现，你知道，接着有了迈克·梅尔斯，接着有了菲尔·哈特曼，有你，还有塞斯·罗根，数不胜数。金·凯瑞。而且还在继续。金·凯瑞，是的。这还没算上凯瑟琳、安德里亚和所有这些天才们。
I think there is something about, well, Lorne Michaels' theory is that, especially with characters that they, that we had more patience for odd behavior in Canada. But I don't really know why. I know that when in 1972, when I started off now, I'm in God's Bell, there was a scene in Toronto of talented people like you couldn't believe. There was John Candy, there was Danny Ackler, there's Gilda, Eugene, and all these people. And you go, but I remember, I used to go with Gilda and I remember the first person in our group that went down to New York to get a job was Paul Schaefer.
我觉得有这么回事，嗯，洛恩·迈尔斯的理论是，特别是对于那些角色，我们在加拿大对古怪行为有更多的耐心。但我真的不知道为什么。我知道在1972年，当我刚开始的时候，我在“上帝的咒骂”（God's Spell），多伦多当时有着你简直难以置信的才华横溢的人才圈子。有约翰·坎迪，有丹尼·阿克罗伊德，有吉尔达，尤金，还有所有这些人。然后你会觉得，但我记得，我以前和吉尔达在一起，我记得我们这群人中第一个去纽约找工作的人是保罗·谢弗。
He was working on the magic show, the Doug Hennings show. And Stephen Schwartz had written the music and he had done God's Bell. So he hired Paul to be a pianist on that show. And I remember in Gilda's kitchen, phoning Paul, the two of us are like this. And Gilda says, Paul, what are New York afterists like? And Paul said, well, I don't, maybe you're my friends. I think you guys are just as talented. And we got off the phone saying, ah, how sweet.
他在一个魔术秀——道格·亨宁秀上工作。斯蒂芬·施瓦茨写了音乐，而且他做过《上帝的咒骂》。所以他雇保罗在那个节目里当钢琴师。我记得在吉尔达的厨房里，给保罗打电话，我们俩就像这样。吉尔达说：“保罗，纽约的艺人是什么样的？”保罗说：“嗯，我不知道，也许你们是我的朋友。我觉得你们也一样有才华。”我们挂了电话说：“啊，多好的人啊。”
What a friend. Because as Canadians, we just didn't really, it seemed like you were Neptune. It didn't seem realistic that you could ever, you know, go to, you know, New York, live on Hollywood and work. So is any of that true? No, no. In fact, you know what? I have the wrong, I put the wrong lenses in, I'm reading it and I struggle.
多么好的朋友。因为作为加拿大人，我们真的没有，感觉就像在海王星一样。觉得你永远不可能，你知道，去，你知道，纽约，在好莱坞生活并工作，这很不现实。所以这些都是真的吗？不，不。事实上，你知道吗？我拿错了，我戴错了眼镜，我在读它，我读得很吃力。
I just want to ask one question before we wrap up. John Candy. Yeah. Obviously, you guys did SCTV together. What was your relationship like with John Candy? What was he like? Was he just the greatest guy with the most naturally funny guy? I was very close friend of mine.
在结束之前我只想问一个问题。约翰·坎迪。对。显然，你们一起做过《SCTV》。你和约翰·坎迪的关系怎么样？他是个什么样的人？他是不是那种最棒的、最具有天然幽默感的人？他曾是我非常亲密的朋友。
We, you know, we did second city stage and we did, but and SCTV, John was exactly what you would hope he was. He was generous and funny. That was actually his laugh and he was the sweetest, kindest, most generous. I remember one night, we were all, you know, we were all on the stage, we were all making the same money and I'm driving home and I said to Nancy, John always picks up the tab and yet he makes the same money I do and it just, it was, no, I'm paying. He was, it was, there was like kind of a Ralph Prampton great grand quality to him.
我们，你知道，我们演过第二城舞台，我们演过，但是还有《SCTV》，约翰完全就是你所希望的那样。他慷慨又幽默。那其实就是他的笑声，他是最甜蜜、最善良、最慷慨的人。我记得有一天晚上，我们都在，你知道，我们都在舞台上，我们赚着同样的钱，我开车回家，我对南希说，约翰总是买单，然而他赚得和我一样多，这简直，这不是，不，我来付钱。他身上有一种拉尔夫·克兰普顿式的伟大品质。
And he was, he was a masterful person. I just, I, you know, there's like, what was that SCTV game show you guys just do? It was like the stupidest people. Halfwits. Halfwits. So Eugene, let me, he's the host and then you got John Candy and Andrea and Joe Flaherty and Marty and they're all, they're the dumbest people and they're the contestants. John Candy's the first one they say, I forget the guy's name, like, Hey, Gary, what do you
他是一个大师级的人物。我只是，你知道，有，你们刚才演的是哪个《SCTV》游戏节目来着？就像是最蠢的人。半白痴（Halfwits）。半白痴。所以尤金，你看，他是主持人，然后有约翰·坎迪、安德里亚、乔·弗莱厄蒂和玛蒂，他们全都是最蠢的人，他们是参赛者。约翰·坎迪是第一个被问到的，我忘了那家伙的名字，就像是，嘿，加里，你是做什么的？
do? Well, I got a job. We answered like, do you have a family? I do. Well, was that a huge inspiration for you? That show as a kid. Loved SCTV, of course. And as a Canadian, really identified and was so proud that there was something Canadian
嗯，我有份工作。我们回答说，你有家庭吗？我有。嗯，那对你来说是一个巨大的启发吗？作为一个孩子的那个节目。当然喜欢《SCTV》了。作为一个加拿大人，真的很有共鸣，而且为有这样一种加拿大的东西感到骄傲。
that all these guys, most of them were actually Canadian, except for maybe. Well, Andrea is born important mate. Right. And Joe Flaherty is from Pittsburgh. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah. Yeah. Like, of course.
所有这些家伙，他们大多数其实都是加拿大人，除了可能。嗯，安德里亚是在英国出生的。没错。而乔·弗莱厄蒂来自匹兹堡。哦，我不知道这个。对。对。就像，当然。
So for us, like for me, as a young guy, watching these guys and so funny and so, and they're doing kind of what you were saying, like, you guys are doing it here. This is incredible. Like this is, it's, it's, it's funny, you know, funnier than anything else. And it's ours. I took, you know, like a lot of Canadians, I was so proud of it and really aspired to do something like that. Although I was too dumb to get into sketch comedy.
所以对我们来说，就像对我来说，作为一个年轻人，看着这些家伙，这么搞笑，而且，他们做的事有点像你刚才说的，就像，你们在这里做着这件事。这太不可思议了。就像这，这，这很有趣，你知道，比其他任何东西都好笑。而且这是我们的。我当时，你知道，就像很多加拿大人一样，我为此感到非常骄傲，并且非常渴望做那样的事情。虽然我太笨了，没能进sketch喜剧（素描喜剧）。
I asked me once, like, why don't you ever get into sketch, I was like, huh, it's not too late. I never thought of that as an option. What about stand up, Marty? Did you ever do any of that? I didn't. I did it once. I did it once after I left second city stage.
有人曾问我，为什么你从来不进sketch喜剧，我当时想，哈，现在也不晚。我从来没把那当作一个选项。那单口喜剧呢，玛蒂？你做过那种吗？我没有。我做过一次。离开第二城舞台后我做过一次。
I thought I'm going to do, I know what I'll do this week and I'll write a stand up act. And I had a friend, Carol poke, and she was in a punk rock group called rough trade. And I said, she said, we'll open for us. We're playing at the Edgerton, so this is nightclub. And I got up and the whole crowd was just, you know, cats and carvings and two people dressed as my deceased parents in the front row. They were intimidating is what I'm saying. And I really bombed and a guy threw a beer in my face.
我想我要去，我知道这周我要做什么，我会写一个单口喜剧表演。我有个朋友，卡罗尔·波克，她在支离破碎（Rough Trade）朋克乐队里。我说，她说，给我们暖场吧。我们在埃格顿演出，这是一个夜总会。我一上台，满场观众就只是，你知道，发嘘声和恶作剧，前排还有两个人打扮成我已故父母的样子。我想说的是，他们太具有恐吓性了。我真的砸场子了，有个家伙往我脸上泼了一杯啤酒。
And then I left the stage and I think I said, hey, I'm not on a diet, this is a light beer, tried that. And I had no material, I had no material. I didn't want people to laugh as much as, you know, randomly turn to each other and go. Exactly. You know, I want to do a reference to Camus. And this is a punk rock group audience.
然后我离开舞台，我想我说过，嘿，我不是在节食，这是淡啤酒，试试这个吧。我当时没有段子，我没有任何段子。比起让大家笑，我更希望大家，你知道，随机地转过头去对彼此说。正是如此。你知道，我想引用加缪。而这是一群朋克摇滚乐队的观众。
And so anyway, I remember going backstage afterwards and Carol came in and we're just in crying on Marty. I'm so sorry. Tomorrow night, it will be so different. And I said, yes, because I'll be home watching Mike Connors on Manics. I will not be here. I was the only time I ever did stand up. Oh, wow.
所以无论如何，我记得事后回到后台，卡罗尔进来了，我们就在那儿哭，玛蒂。我太抱歉了。明天晚上，一切都会大不相同的。我说，是的，因为我会回家看迈克·康纳斯的《曼尼克斯》。我不会呆在这里。那是我唯一一次表演单口喜剧。哦，哇。
And then, you know, as I do shows now, I ended up my own shows. You kind of do a form of monologue, but never, I never close. Marty, what is what is the rest of the day for you? What type are you? Are you are you a homebody? Do you like, do you like to just take it into maybe a five o'clock dinner and an eight o'clock sleep? I will tell you exactly what I'm going to do at four o'clock, I'm having a very hip
然后，你知道，随着我现在做节目，我最终有了自己的节目。你多少会做一种独白的形式，但从不，我从不收尾。玛蒂，你的余下一天是怎么度过的？你是什么类型的人？你是宅男吗？你喜欢，你喜欢直接过渡到一个五点的晚餐和八点的睡眠吗？我来告诉你我四点钟要做什么，我要和克里斯托弗·盖斯特先生去进行一次非常时髦的戴着口罩的社交散步，我是他的超级粉丝，他是有史以来最伟大的天才。我也喜欢他的妻子。杰米·李，她有一次对我说，我当时在拍电影《铁窗喋血》（Captain Ron），她说，马克，这部电影是关于什么的？我说，嗯，我饰演一个带着两个孩子继承了一条船的男人。她说，我没让你剧透。玛蒂，非常感谢你来到节目。
masks on social walk with Mr. Christopher Guest, such a big fan, the greatest genius of them all. I love his wife, too. Jamie Lee, he once said to me, I was making a film Captain Ron and he said, Mark, what's this film about? I said, well, I play a man with two children who inherits a boat. He said, I didn't say, spoil it for me. Marty, thank you so much for coming on the show.
我们真的很感激。我们比以前更爱你。我说的对吗？100%。我爱马丁·肖特。我也爱你们三个。非常荣幸和高兴能来到你们的节目，麦奎尔姐妹播客。
We really appreciate it. We love you even more than we already did. Am I right? 100%. I love Martin Short. I love you three. Thank you so much. My honor and pleasure to be on your show, the McGuire's Sister Podcast.
我们试着把它清理干净。为什么不呢？我们应该的。我爱你们。谢谢。非常非常爱你们。爱你的，玛蒂。
Let's try to clear it. Why not? We should. I love you. Thank you. Love you. Very, very much. Love you, Marty.
谢谢你，玛蒂。谢谢你，肖恩。散步愉快。再见，威廉。再见。再见。再见。威尔，很棒的嘉宾。
Thanks, Marty. Thank you, Sean. Have a good walk. Bye, William. Bye. Bye. Bye. Will, great guest.
fantastische 嘉宾，威尔。我不知道你是怎么做到的。能请到玛蒂真是太棒了。不是吗？对。他简直是我认识的最搞笑的人。我同意。我同意。
Fantastic guest, Will. I don't know how you do it. It was great to have Marty. Wasn't it? Yeah. He's literally the funniest person I've ever known. I agree. I agree.
而且他就是那种人，就像我说的，你知道，我只是作为一个年轻的加拿大人——我依然是个年轻的加拿大人——我想这家伙，我的意思是，你知道，他和我来自同一个地方，你知道，他就是，而且可能也是我认识的最搞笑的人。对。他和史蒂夫·马丁是我两大巨大的灵感来源。所以他早期对你是个启发，是吗？哦，当然。
And he was one of those guys, like I said, that, you know, I just thought as a young Canadian, and I'm still a young Canadian, I thought how this guy, I mean, you know, he's from where I'm from and, you know, he was just, but also maybe the funniest person I've ever known. Yeah. Him and Steve Martin were my two big, huge inspirations. So he was an early inspiration for you, yeah? Oh, for sure.
对。百分之百。对。SCTV。那为什么你没有去演素描喜剧？说实话，我太笨了。不，拜托。我从来没考虑过。
Yeah. Kind of percent. Yeah. SETV. Then why didn't you go into sketch comedy? Honestly, I was too dumb. No, come on. I never considered it.
我从来没想过。我经常说的一套套回答是，当我年轻的时候，我想被人认真对待。所以我认为我会成为，我总是胡闹，我觉得自己相对搞笑，但我不认为那是我能做、能胜任的事情。我有过这样的时刻：哦，该死，我真希望自己能去演素描，或者我真希望自己能进第二城剧团或尝试走那条路。所以你早期在想你要走戏剧演员的路线，而喜剧对你来说只是一种个人生活中的消遣。
I never thought about it. I've said that my sort of rote answer is, when I was young, I wanted to be taken seriously. So I thought I'd be, I always goofed around and I thought I was relatively funny, but I didn't think that it was something that I could do, do. And I've had moments of like, oh, God damn it, I wish I'd gotten into sketch or I wish I'd gotten to Second City or tried to do that route. And so you were thinking early on that you were going to go the root of a dramatic actor and the comedy was just sort of in for your just personal life.
对。一样。绝对是的。就是这样。我也一样。直到我开始被学校开除，我才意识到，哦，我的这张嘴，也许我应该把它用在更好的地方。嗯，我记得当我还是个青少年的时候，有人对我说过，他们说，我太贫嘴了，嘴皮子太厉害了，他们说，你让我想起了《这是你的行动》（It's Your Move）里的那个孩子。拜托。我不知道我有没有跟你说过这个。真的吗？对。这些年来我从来没跟你说过。对。
Yeah. Same. Absolutely. That was it. Same here. It wasn't until I started getting kicked out of schools that I realized that, oh, my mouth is, maybe I should put it to better use. Well, I remember somebody saying to me once when I was a teenager, they said, I was such
你知道，多年前对我说，你让我想起了《这是你的行动》里的那个孩子，那是杰森的节目，实际上是《银匙》（Silver Spoons）的衍生剧。《银匙》。对。我记得那个。对。你还记得吗，肖恩？而杰森曾出演《银匙》。
a smart ass and I had such a wise mouth and they said, you remind me of that kid on It's Your Move. Come on. I don't know if I've ever told you that. Truly? Yeah. I've never told you that over all these years. Yeah.
他演得太好了，以至于他们给了他自己的节目。那个节目持续了一季。几乎一季。对。不，我想收视率还可以，但当时他们有个叫研究的东西，NBC研究，有家长写信给NBC抱怨说，他们的孩子在模仿编剧写给我角色的那些恶作剧和恶作剧。对。
You know, years ago said to me, you remind me of that kid on It's Your Move, which was Jason's show that it was a spinoff in effect of Silver Spoons. Silver Spoons. Yeah. I remember that. Yeah. Do you remember that, Sean? And Jason was on Silver Spoons.
所以他们要求他们把这方面稍微收敛一点，这有点变成了那种公关问题，可能收视率也没能让它变得无可辩驳。所以他们就把它砍了。你是不是有点像那种，你是个贫嘴的、没有大人看管的钥匙儿童，你有个单亲妈妈？是这样吗？一个小贩，一个小贩，住在公寓楼里，然后，你知道，是的，偷考试答案和别人公寓的钥匙以及所有诸如此类的东西。但想象一下，当我们开始一起工作并成为朋友时，我是多么高兴，我意识到
He was so good basically that they gave him his own show. And the show lasted one season. Almost one season. Yeah. No, I think the ratings were okay, but at that point, they had this thing called research, NBC research, was parents were writing letters to NBC complaining that their kids were doing some of the same scams and pranks that the writers were writing my character to do. Right.
你和那个角色的相似度有多高。对。我不太喜欢演戏。所以我只挑选那些就在我边界之内的角色。这就是为什么，你可不应该这么说，因为你这辈子洗过很多黑钱。我迷恋你，杰森，在《霍根一家》（The Hogan Family）里，简直从来没有错过任何一集。
So they asked them to kind of dial back on that and it became sort of like this PR problem and probably the ratings didn't make it undeniable either. So they just axed it. Were you kind of like a, you were like a smart ass, like latchkey kid, you had a single mom? Is that right? A dealer, dealer living in an apartment building and, you know, yeah, stealing answers to tests and keys to people's apartments and all that kind of stuff. But imagine my delight when we first started working together, became friends and I realized
拜托。就像这家伙是最棒的、最搞笑的，哦天哪。你知道，那是让我想要演戏的节目之一，纯粹因为那个节目。你是认真的吗？你从来没跟我说过这个。对。我现在告诉你。
how close to that character you really are. Yeah. I don't like to do a lot of acting. So I just pick the characters that are just inside my borders. Which is why, and you, you shouldn't say that because you have done a lot of money laundering in your life. I obsessed, I obsessed over you, Jason, on the Hogan family, like never, ever missed an episode.
这就是我的感受。当我第一次看《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）时，我想，天哪，我要退出娱乐圈了，因为去他妈的。你知道我的意思吗？看看会发生什么，胡说八道，那是胡说八道。就在那儿。电视上的同性恋。
Come on. Like this guy is the greatest, funniest, oh my God. And you know, that was one of the shows where I was like, I want to do that just because of that show. Are you serious? You never told me that. Yeah. I'm telling you now.
但是如果我们，这三个人的职业生涯加起来，能不能，能不能，能不能比得上马丁·肖特以及他所拥有的作品量、角色、赞誉和时代 relevance。还有笑声，每...的笑声量，他创造的笑声总量简直令人难以企及。嗯，那很有趣。对，他是最棒的。你学到了，你今天从玛蒂那里学到了一些东西。我不知道医学院那件事。我以前真不知道。
And that's how I felt. When I first watched Will and Grace, I thought, man, I'm going to quit show biz because fuck this. You know what I mean? Look what can happen, bullshit, that is bullshit. Right there. Gays on TV. But if we, if the, I don't think the three of our careers could, could, could equal Martin
对。我也不知道。嗯，我确实知道，他是一个多么善良、正派、有耐心、有吸引力的人。嗯，我，你知道，我不知道他已经70岁了。我的意思是，从外表看不出来，你看，跑起来像个30岁的人，他看起来棒极了。看起来棒极了。他，他在拼命工作。我的意思是，这就是我20年后的理想状态。
Schwartz and the amount of work and characters and admiration and relevance he has. And laughs and laughs per, like the, the actual tonnage of laughs that he's created are almost insurmountable. Well, that was fun. Yeah, he's the best. Did you learn, you learned some stuff about Marty today. I didn't know the medical school thing. I did not know that.
我的意思是，他没有去，他短暂地去过医学院，但他仍然是个业余直肠指检专家。对。你有他的电话号码吗？嗯，哼。好的，太好了。嗯，我想我下次会再见到你们。嗯，这就是部分，让我看一下我的剧本。
Yeah. I did not know that either. Um, I did know, uh, what an incredibly kind, decent, patient, uh, engaging guy he is. Um, I, I, you know, I didn't know he was 70. I mean, you can't tell from, look, I mean, running around like he's 30, he looks great. It looks great. He's, he's working his tail off. I mean, that's where I'd like to be in 20 years.
哦，这就是我该说再见的时候。再见。叮咚。对。聪明。什么。聪明。
I mean, he didn't go to, he went to medical school briefly, but he's still an amateur proctologist. Yeah. Do you have his number? Mm hmm. Okay, great. Well, um, I guess I'll see you guys next time. Um, this is the part, let me just look at my script.
什么。聪明。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。
Oh, this is where I go. Bye. Bye. Ding-dong. Yeah. Smart. What. Smart.
什么。这个节目还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
What. Smart. What. What. What. What. What. What.
什么。聪明。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。
What. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
什么。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。